Hey Paul,
when are you going to finish?
What do you mean?
When are you going to finish talking
about I talky?
Oh,
I'm already finished.
Okay,
good.
Because you have a language video to
make.
Oh,
that's right.
What language does it today finish?
Yeah,
yeah,
I'm finished.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the
Finnish language.
As you probably know,
finish is the majority language spoken
in Finland.
It has about 5.4
million native speakers with 4.9
million of them living in Finland,
which is about 90% of the population of
Finland.
It's one of the two official languages
of Finland along with Swedish,
which is spoken by about 5% of the
population and there were also finished
speaking minorities across the border in
Russia,
in Norway and in Sweden.
You may have seen my video on the north
dramatic languages.
It's this one right here and you might
remember that I specifically excluded
finish from that video.
That's because even though Finland is a
Nordic country with geographic and
historical connections to Scandinavia,
the Finnish language is not an north
Germanic language.
In fact,
it's not even an Indo European language.
It is part of the Finnish language
group,
which is a branch of the urologic
language family.
Other members of the finet group,
our Estonian Cornellian,
Ludic Vips,
ingredient votech and Livonians,
but finish is the most widely spoken
language in the Finnish language group.
All the Finnick languages developed from
Prodo Finnick,
which was spoken around 3000 years ago.
The first stage was early Prodo Finnick.
Then during the middle protal finnick
period,
some changes took place in that language
and it's split into two protos Samak,
the ancestor of the Cemak languages and
late Prodo Finnick,
which ultimately became the most recent
ancestor of all the Finnick languages.
It's worth noting that finished contains
a significant number of Germanic loan
words,
some of them which are clearly ancient
in origin.
For example,
kooning gas,
which means king do lead,
which means chair,
and it comes from the same root as stool
and gold loops,
which means school from words like
these,
we can see that the ancient fins had
extensive contact with Germanic peoples.
Linked Prodo Finnick diverged into three
dialects,
eastern Prodo,
Finnick,
northern Prodo,
Finnick and southern Prodo Finnick.
These three dialects of Lake Prodo
finnick mixed with each other and the
resulting mixes of influences developed
into the dialects that make up the
Finnish language.
Around the 12th Century and 13th century
Ce Sweden conquered Finland and made it
a province of their country and for the
next few hundred years,
Swedish was the language of
administration and during this time the
middle low German was the Lingua Franca
of commerce in the area and Latin was
the language of religion.
Swedish and middle low German left an
additional dramatic influence on
finished,
which during that time was strictly a
language of daily communication.
Finished did not really become a written
language until the 16th century.
When a finished bishop named Mikael
Agricola created the first comprehensive
writing system for the language.
He based that system on the orthography
of German,
Swedish,
and Latin,
and it still forms the basis of the
finished writing system today,
although there have been changes since
then.
In 1809 Russia seized Finland from
Sweden in a war and made it an
autonomous state as part of the Russian
empire.
The official language and the language
of the elite remained Swedish,
but finished national feeling and a
desire to make the Finnish language
dominant began to increase in 1835 these
feelings were amplified by the
publication of culliver law or work of
epic poetry written by alias Loon
wrought with stories from carilion and
finish folklore and mythology.
Luna [inaudible] also played an
important role in the development of
standard finish in 1863 finish became an
official language in Finland alongside
the Swedish language and they both
remain official languages today and with
a new sense of national identity
emerging Finland eventually gained
independence from Russia in 1917 before
standard finish was created.
The Finnish language consisted of a
number of dialects that could be roughly
divided into eastern and western
dialects.
The Western dialects are the ones upon
which standard finish was largely based.
From what I understand these days,
the dialects mostly consist of
differences in accent,
but outside of Finland there are a few
interesting dialects that are officially
considered to be different languages
even though they are intelligible with
standard finish.
This includes the Corelli in language
and Russia may Anchia Lee,
which is spoken by a Finnish minority
and Sweden and Kevin,
which is spoken by a minority in Norway.
So what is the Finnish language like?
Well,
it shares some features with the other
members of the Finnish language group.
Some of those features are no
grammatical gender.
There was no distinction between
masculine,
feminine or Neuter,
not even in the personal pronouns.
Hum.
It means both he and she,
and interestingly,
Finland was one of the first countries
to grant women the right to vote and it
was one of the first to have a female
president.
So maybe gender equality is just built
into the language and way of thinking.
Hey,
you never know.
Next no articles.
Articles are the words like [inaudible]
or the in English.
English speakers often wonder how you
can communicate without those articles,
but the context usually provides enough
meaning that you don't actually need the
articles.
Next finish has some prepositions in
English.
Those are words showing location or
relationship like two or apps or on,
but finish has many more post positions.
These are similar to prepositions in
function,
but they come after the word that they
add meaning to rather than before.
Here's an example sentence with the post
position already on Coppola.
Guess Scala.
The sentence means the market is in the
center of town.
Toady means market on is similar to his
Kalpa me is town.
The end at the end of [inaudible] is the
genitive case showing possession and
then after Kelp lumion we have
cascadilla which is the post position,
which means in the middle,
so it's supposed to position because it
comes after the now Kalpa me next,
lots of grammatical cases,
15 to be precise.
That means that now it's personal
pronouns and adjectives have 15
different forms depending on their
function in the sentence.
We can't look at all 15 right now,
but let's look at an example.
Finish has the accusative case which
marks a direct object and that's common
in lots of languages.
It can be shown with an end at the end
of the word or it can be shown with
nothing just left blank at the end of
the word,
but there is also something called the
positive case.
This also marks a direct object.
If the object is only part of a whole or
if the action is incomplete or if the
action is negative shift,
go call on this sentence means will you
eat the fish should means you eat.
Cool.
Here's a question.
Marker.
Color is fish and the end at the end of
color is the accusative case showing
that the action will be completed and
that the whole fish will be eaten.
Just cacala means do you eat fish?
So again,
shoot is you eat,
cook,
it's the question marker.
Color is fish and the [inaudible] at the
end of color is the positive case which
shows that there's no completed action.
There's no completed action because
there's no specific fish being eaten.
This is just a general question.
Next,
you may have noticed in the above
example sentences that the present tense
and future tense are the same.
That's right in finished.
There is no future tense,
but the future can be indicated in a
couple of ways.
When you see a present tense verb with
an accusative case object like this that
indicates the future because it shows
that the action will be complete at some
point.
When you see a present tense verb with
the part of the case like this,
that indicates present tense because the
action is not a completed action,
so what must be happening now?
The future can also be clarified with a
time expression.
Here's an example of demonstrating that
there is no future tense in Finnish
fluid.
This means I read one woman.
This means I will read to moral who am
in not means tomorrow,
and that time expression is what
indicates that this action will take
place in the future.
Next,
there are a lot of long words and finish
because of a gluten nation and because
of compound words finishes in a gluten
native language,
meaning that words can be formed by
attaching together pieces that add
meaning to the word.
Without those pieces changing,
you just attach them together.
In English we might use separate words
like conjunctions and prepositions,
but in finished special endings can be
added to a word stem.
Here's an example starting with the word
for house.
Hello.
Hello Sir.
Hello,
is sonny boy's soon again.
Hello.
So Nikki go
and the few additional features of
finish.
Number one,
the main stress always goes on the first
syllable of the word.
Number two,
there was no equivalent of the verb to
have in finish.
Number three finish has negative verb
conjugations.
That means that instead of using a
negation word like not,
it has an entirely different form of the
verb to show that it's negative.
Finish is clearly a very interesting
language that might be quite different
from the languages that you're used to
speaking and learning.
But it's finished as hard to learn as
people say it is.
Well,
I can't tell you from personal
experience,
but it seems to me that if you've never
learned a language from the finet group,
we're from the your relic language
family before,
then you'll probably have to bend your
mind a little bit to understand how that
language works and that'll probably take
more focus and effort then learning a
language that's more similar to your
own,
but as is always the case,
your passion,
any language or culture will carry you
through the challenges of learning that
language.
So if you're fascinated by finished,
you really should go for it.
Okay.
The question of the day for finished
speakers,
how noticeable or the finished dialects
today,
can you tell where a finished speaker
was from just by hearing them speak and
a different question for people who've
studied finish,
how challenging is finished to learn?
Did you find it quite tough or did you
just find it different?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Thanks again to all my patrion
supporters for your continued support
and everyone else.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.